con el agua hasta la cintura estos
soldados tienen una difícil misión deben
abrir puertas de coches e inspeccionar
cada vehículo en busca de personas que
pudieron haberse quedado sin tiempo para
escapar antes de la llegada de la
inundación el ejército ha movilizado
todos sus recursos para reabrir esta
autovía en donde la inundación provocó
que algunos vehículos quedaran apilados
unos sobre otros los soldados han estado
sacando los uno a uno tenemos 28
vehículos aquí el agua ha comenzado a
descender pero todavía no sabemos si hay
personas dentro de los coches esperamos
que todo el mundo consiguiera salir a
tiempo en alemania las consecuencias de
las inundaciones empeoran con las horas
en esta región la atmósfera es sombría
al final de la calle los equipos de
rescate están dando una terrible noticia
a un residente han encontrado en el
garaje el cuerpo sin vida de uno de sus
familiares
una tragedia para la familia y un trauma
para el país
en la prensa alemana se están publicando
decenas de fotos de personas
desaparecidas y para muchos se hace
insoportable hay demasiados muertos lo
siento no puedo más
en algunas ciudades ha habido muestras
masivas de solidaridad con cientos de
donaciones recibidas en unas horas